de acuerdo con el pictograma mostrado
abajo cuántos participantes de la
encuesta tienen tipo de sangre o
positiva cuántos tienen o negativa un
pictograma es básicamente representar
información o datos con gráficas o
imágenes que están relacionadas con
información en este caso nos están
mostrando imágenes de lo que yo asumo
son gotitas de sangre y nos dicen que
cada una de estas gotas de sangre es
equivalente en este pictograma
representa a 8 personas se puede ver
como una escala de estas gráficas por
ejemplo cuántas personas tienen tipo de
sangre a positiva pues contamos las
gotas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 gotitas de sangre
cada gota equivale a 8 personas por lo
que 7 x 8 es igual a 56 por lo que 56
personas tienen tipo de sangre a
positivo vamos a responder la pregunta
que nos están haciendo aquí cuántas
personas que respondieron esta encuesta
tiene un tipo de sangre o positiva nos
interesa la hoja
y que sea positiva así que tenemos 1 2 3
vamos a hacerlo en otro color tenemos 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 gotitas de sangre 8
gotitas lo pongo entre comillas porque
son dibujos de gotas y no gotas reales y
la escala es de 8 personas por cada gota
vamos a escribirlo bien 8 personas
ocho personas por gota
8 x 8 es igual a 64 incluso vemos que
esta parte de las gotas se cancela si
estuviéramos trabajando con unidades
quitamos esto nos queda que 8 por 8 64
personas tienen tipo de sangre o
positiva 64 personas tienen tipo de
sangre positiva y ahora veamos cuántas
tienen tipo de sangre o negativa veamos
nuestras gotitas y esto es negativo
tenemos una dos gotitas dos gotas
dos gotas por ocho personas por gota por
gota dos por ocho va a ser igual a 16 16
personas así que 16 personas de las que
respondieron la encuesta tienen tipos de
sangre o negativa y 64 tiene un tipo de
sangre o positiva